welcome to the last Talk of the first
day so the last talk is by Max Hopkins
and he's going to tell us about
integrity gaps so thrilling and relation
to high Dimensions final so take it away
Max thanks to our uh thanks so much
everyone for for coming to the last
session of the day uh hopefully you can
stay awake for the next hour but if not
no worries uh you know we know how it is
um
um yeah so I'll be talking about uh this
work on explicit SOS uh lower bounds are
integrality gaps within the sum of
squares hierarchy based on some new
Notions of high dimensional expenders uh
this is Joint work with Ching Chun Lin
or David who's probably here somewhere
yeah there he is thanks
um okay so I want to start with just
some high level background on what sum
of squares is we'll keep this relatively
high level and then I'll go into a
specific problem 3x or it will be a
little bit more detailed but really even
though you know there's SOS in the title
of this talk you you really won't need
to know anything about SOS for this uh
for this talk so just briefly at a high
level
T sum of squares
sdp hierarchy
it's essentially a very powerful
framework for constrained polynomial
optimization problems so this is a
framework
polynomial optimization
and it's particularly powerful for
solving computer science's favorite
problems constraint satisfaction
problems and we'll talk about a specific
one in a second uh many classical CSP
algorithms turned out to be captured by
say constantly maybe many what are
called rounds of the SOS hierarchy and
we actually know from beautiful work of
AG Avenger that under the unique games
conjecture that the sum of squares
hierarchy optimally approximates the
value for for all CSP so this is a very
very powerful framework
roughly speaking you can sort of think
of this sdp hierarchy as a computational
model like a restricted model of
computation
that's divided up into levels if I have
an N variable say CSP it'll have levels
ranging from one to n so divided
to
levels
one through and and roughly speaking I
just sort of want to mention t uh two
things the teeth level of the hierarchy
basically looks at sort of ensembles of
T variables at once along with some low
degree consistency constraints
um so sort of looks at
very informally sets of T variables
at once
and critically it runs in time like end
of the year of T so if you have a
constant round thing it runs in
polynomial
time run time and the of t on the other
hand when you reach the top of the
hierarchy at level n we can see all the
variables and you can essentially like
brute force over the solutions we can
level n we'll we'll solve any uh CSP
okay that was sort of the only high
level things I wanted to say about uh
sum of squares and now I want to focus
on a specific constraint satisfaction
problem that I imagine everybody in the
room is familiar with which is just 3x
or one of the most classical constraint
satisfaction problems we study in
complexity
so what is 3x or I probably don't need
to write this out but I will so an
instance of 3x or on on N variables this
will consist of a a set of variables x i
where I ranges from 1 through n and a
family of clauses
and we'll
we'll write that there are M Clauses and
for the sake of this talk I mean
actually the paper that I'll be talking
about I'll note that M should always be
thought of as linear and and there'll be
like 100 n Clauses or a thousand n
Clauses or something like that
um and okay what's the form of these
Clauses they're just linear equations
with three variables right so this the
Clause CJ
it's going to be something like
xj1 Plus xj2
what's xj3 and then there's some literal
that I set them equal to they're either
equal to zero or to one so we're equal
to some beta J
and F2
okay so that's an instance of of three
xor uh what are we interested in well
we're interested in calculating the
instances value which is the maximum
number of constraints that I can satisfy
At Once by some F2 assignment to the
variance all right so the value
right value of i n this is uh again the
maximum over
over assignments of of x to the
variables
um
of the the value which I'll just write
out explicitly here so that it matches
the STP over there
um and you can compute that the the
value of a particular X is the sum over
the clauses
of just making sure that the the beta J
is equal to the the sine of you know
negative one to the beta J is equal to
the sine of negative one two this clause
okay so there's an explicit formula for
the value notice that if I'm doing this
over F2 because eventually when we move
to talking about lower bounds it'll be
useful to have things sort of additive
notation if if I switch to plus minus 1
to the N these would be multiplying and
this would be like a polynomial
optimization problem which is where SOS
comes into the picture
um
so let's actually move over very briefly
through the level T sum of squares SCP
relaxation uh maybe I'll wait for the
the screen to adjust so everyone can see
this give me a knot
um I don't want to actually say that
much about this this relaxation for
every subset of variables of size up to
D I introduce a new sort of vector
valued relaxation for
um I'm maximizing some relaxation of
exactly this value and I'll call sort of
the maximum actual maximum of this
program of the node is the sdp value
of iron maybe I'll write a t here if I'm
corresponding to some number of of
levels um and there are constraints here
that that correspond to some consistency
constraints between the variables and
some booleanity constraints but again
it's not that important that we
understand exactly what this program is
uh really the point
on the right hand side of the maximum
what is the stat on what is what is this
us or the variable so everywhere
this or the end part of the right
direction
so this is supposed to stand for like
the ones standard thing or one second
yeah okay sorry
um okay really the only point that I
want to make about this is that it's a
relaxation in the sense that the STP
value lies somewhere between the true
value of the instance
and this you get just by sort of
plugging in the actual the relaxation of
actual Solutions and
and one because of how I've normalized
things this will always cop out at work
so what was the point of this well now
I'm going to Define what it means to be
hard or to have a lower bound against
sum of squares
um and so we'll
say that a family
um so typically when we talk about uh
lower bounds and complexity we like to
talk about not specific instances right
you could hard code an algorithm for
specific instance but an infinite family
of of instances so we'll have some sort
of infinite family
of three xor instances with M scaling to
infinity and we'll say they're hard for
sum of squares in particular
um
uh actually something more will ask that
they are hard to
approximate
if there exists a constant
uh mu in zero one
such that for all uh for all n for all
of these instances uh we have the
following two properties
first is usually referred to as
soundness and this is just going to say
that the instances are very far from
being the true value of the instances is
small it's far from being satisfied but
the value
of i n should be less than or equal to
Mu so there's some number that's bounded
away from one with respect to the size
of of n you know 99 or something like
that and I can never satisfy more than
99 of the pauses at once so these are
these are highly unsatisfiable instances
and yet
completeness
uh will mean that you know nevertheless
the sdp value will be as poor as
possible so maybe we'll say hardness
against T levels of SOS would mean the
teeth sdp relaxation has value one so
sum of squares cannot determine uh you
know cannot tell that this instance is
actually very unsatisfiable and and
thinks that it is a fully setup that
there is a fully satisfying solution and
you know notice that
why do I say hardness of approximation
here well you could ask for something a
little bit less which is like maybe I
just want to ask that this is less than
one and not bounded away you know this
might be something like 1 minus one over
n or something that scales with n and
this doesn't give a lower bound against
approximation right because the value is
one minus one over n and one will be
within some you know any constant of
each other for large enough n so I
actually need to be like bounded away
from one to give it an approximate
ability result which will be what the
focus of this talk is
um
so here's sort of the main
question
for this talk
uh
which is what csps in particular we'll
look at what instances of 3x or
are hard for some of squares
um
there is a very classical answer to this
question
and it's the first thing that I want to
talk about so some background on what we
know about this
and this is a result that was originally
proved by gregoriov in 99 and then it
was rediscovered by Shawna back in in
2008 and it's a beautiful theorem
so uh gregoriov
Australia back
oh eight and it says first I'll just say
informally
it says that random instances random
families of 3x or are basically
optimally hard so Random
xor
r
and let me be a little bit more explicit
um so if we have
you know some n variables and we'll pick
say M random clauses
probably a little bit more specific
about exactly what it means to pick a
random clause in a bit but it's just
what you think
um then the following two properties
hold
with with high probability over uh over
these choices uh the soundness is is
near optimal the value
of i n will be
less than half Clips Epsilon where
Epsilon is really something that scales
with like the constant on this uh on the
number of Clauses I'm not going to go
too much into the relationship here but
notice that this is optimal because in a
3X or instance if I just pick a random
assignment I'm going to satisfy half the
equations and expectations so I'm
clearly not going to do better than than
half so half plus Epsilon is like the
optimal thing that you can hope for
uh
and it will have completeness so the sdp
value
of i n will be equal to one
all the way up
to O of n levels
of SOS so this is a very very strong
remember that n levels of SOS solves
everything so this is an extremely
strong lure about it says all the way up
to some you know n over five or some
some constants uh
linearly many levels
random instances trick sum of squares it
thinks that the value is one
um even though it's sort of ultimately
far okay this is a beautiful theorem and
in building up to the what what the main
thing we'll talk about we'll actually
see the proof of this or a sketch of it
um and this generated a really long line
of work on understanding more generally
the hardness of random constraint
satisfaction problems Beyond 3xor uh
other types of structures independent
set and combinatorial structures
um but something that had remained
as far as I know pretty much completely
open until a year or two ago
is whether the randomness in all of
these constructions was necessary in
particular
um well we already know from the title
but the main question that we'll
actually discuss is sort of whether this
result can be de-randomized or in
particular you know are there
explicit families
are there instances that are
constructible in polynomial time
that are hard for SOS
okay so maybe uh just a comment
you know why if we have sort of this
whole landscape of random things why is
it so hard to get something for the
explicit case
um well first I'll mention that actually
if you want something like you know not
for the approximation regime it's
actually not that hard in fact even
maybe before the random case something
like this was was known for certain
parity systems
um but the reason in general this result
is so much harder or it seems to be is
that deterministic instances things
things that you can construct in
polynomial time they have short
Witnesses they have short proofs of
unsatisfiability and you have to show
that some of squares can't capture these
proofs and you know this is a different
type of statement than showing that some
of squares can't capture like a
churn-off bound which is how you prove
often these sort of basic random things
um
okay
so a couple years ago maybe at end of
2020 or 2021
um there was a really beautiful result
towards this direction of the
neurophilus Harsha and tociani who
showed how to build the first explicit
hard instances against some squares and
let me sort of show uh what exactly what
they proved
um and you know to me this was really
cool because they did it using High
dimensional expanders which is you know
very exciting
um so here's here's sort of what they
proved this is a
neurofilmis
Russia
is in its ranking one
um and they proved the following that
they're
there exists an explicit
uh you know infinite family
of three atturances I have N I don't
know I I won't say exactly what this
means for the moment but we'll sort of
see a variant of it later in the talk
that in some sense sit on a family of
high dimensional expanders so sort of
Define on top of what are called the
ramanujan complexes
which is some uh sort of famous family
of high dimensional expanders um that
satisfy the following guarantees which
we'll sort of compare up here to what we
get for random instances
uh
so the soundness is I didn't recover
half plus Epsilon but uh you know the
value
event I'm gonna cheat a little bit here
I'm just going to make up some constant
I'm not it's some constant that's not
one I'm not totally sure what the right
uh constant is but there's some you that
it's bound the the values bounded away
from from one and then the completeness
uh they show that the sdp value
uh Ali of n is one
up to
uh root log n
levels of SOS
okay
um so let's compare this to the category
of results there's sort of two main
points of comparison
um the first is the soundness value of
being half plus Epsilon remember we said
was was optimal
um versus sort of 99 and this one I'll
mention is is not such a big deal
because it turns out that
um
from much previous work of tulsiani in
in 2009 you can sort of use PCP
reductions to move from this instance to
something with half plus Epsilon albeit
maybe you lose
like a little bit in the completeness or
you can actually not lose in
completeness and moves in levels but
um this is this is not such a huge issue
we sort of know how to reduce the
instances that have optimal gaps
um this seems to be the bigger issue
um this had to do with uh some
properties of the Roman engine complex
that was very unclear how to improve on
um and you know it doesn't uh you know
approaching it's not even polynomial
much much less you know close to this
linear hardness
um and in fact uh there was an
interesting observation from from Kevin
Pratt who's maybe also here
um which who who observed that you can
actually get
you know instances verse about login
Levels by some sort of Brute Force
argument over over small random
instances so that was a little
disappointing because I really like this
sort of application of high dimensional
expanders
um and I I really wanted this to be the
right direction
um and you know thankfully last year uh
in in this joint work with uh with David
Lin we sort of fixed the version of this
results and we showed that this approach
uh you know we follow very closely sort
of this approach htx based approach of
the neurophilus archaunfelsiani
um and we show that this is indeed you
know if not the right approach a right
approach and so we proved sort of the
following
theorem which I'll redo it
in red
there are only two changes
the rambunation complexes are replaced
with an object that I will Define later
on The Talk called the small set High
dimensional expander these are things
that uh ended up coming out of quantum
codes if we have time at the end I'll
talk about this
um and this gets replaced with
indeed linear levels match anger various
result
um
yeah and okay maybe I'll mention that
also you know if you wanted hardness
hard explicit instances for things that
are not xor again you can run these
things through PCP reductions to get
hardness for other instances so this
sort of gives a whole landscape of
explicit hard csps uh for some of
squares
um
okay maybe any questions before so now
I've stated the main results my goal and
the rest of this talk uh yeah Anthony
yeah yeah so there's some trade-off that
you can you can tweak parameters to get
some some sort of trails here yeah is
there some way to to tweak this theorem
to push close to this like one half down
for sound yeah yeah so I mean you can
use PCP reductions to get to half
question absolon like if you use the
long code based like noise reductions
then you lose something in the
completeness
um pair Ashman pointed out that if you
use the Hat Mark code in parallel
repetition then you can maintain perfect
completeness but you end up I think with
something like NV Epsilon levels so
actually achieving both of these
simultaneously is an open problem
um and also actually I'll say just I
mean this is something that the door
brought up to me earlier just sort of
directly achieving one half plus Epsilon
without going through these PCB
reductions and having something that
like sits on a complex would itself be
very interesting and in some sense this
might also correspond to like uh a good
distance Quantum Code so it's sort of an
independently interesting problem with
other other areas
um okay yeah good question
okay so my goal here uh I want to try to
convince you that this notion of high
dimensional expansion actually does
arise pretty naturally when you try to
solve this problem so I'm not going to
start by you know this is like a
topological notion of HDX and I've seen
people many people get talks on top of
logical HDX and when it's yes audience
half the people you know eyes glaze over
so we're gonna we're gonna skip uh that
step and we're gonna try to see how this
arises in within this actual problem
framework
um and then hopefully if we have time
I'll try to show you how you actually
get explicit construction uh of these
objects though I sort of had the feeling
I'll briefly sketch this uh at the end
okay so that's the plan for the rest of
the talk
um so the first thing that I want to do
to show why this type of structure
arises is to go back to this original
result of Gregorio and show my back in
particular will follow uh sort of the
proof within shot him back
um and the the key thing that we'll
observe here is that expansion already
played like a big role in this result
um
so in particular to understand this
it'll be useful
it'll be useful to move to the graph
view of of 3xor so we can always draw
you so we can always draw an instance of
3xor in the following way
we'll have a constraint graph
and I'm now realizing maybe I shouldn't
have erased the instance the definition
of of 3x or this was just you know
things with these Clauses like xj1 plus
xj2 plus xj3
equals beta J right so this left side
is going to be given by the constraint
structure of a graph in particular so
we'll have a bipartite graph where on
one side we have the variables
now this is X1 through x n and then on
the right side we have the clauses
uh so like cha and then you know
following this equation we just connect
CJ to the variables that are in the
Clause right this goes to uh xj1 xj2
xj3
and then okay we're not quite done right
because we've now we've specified this
part of the picture but we also need to
specify sort of the right hand side of
the equation which I'll call the target
function
so we need a constraint graph Plus
Target function
and this will just be a labeling of the
right hand side of this graph right a
zero one labeling and I'll I'll write it
as
beta in
F2 to the C so this is just something
that's you know isomorphic to F2 the M
or M Clauses but you can think about
either of this as like a subset of the
right hand side or a labeling or a
function and I'll probably move between
them uh I'm talking about things because
it's useful to think of them in
different ways
um okay and so now what is you know what
is the random instance that showed up in
this result well I'll fix the number of
pauses see and the variables and then
I'll just pick a random bipartite graph
right for every uh for every vertex here
I'll just pick three random vertices and
draw edges to them and then I'll pick a
uniformly random Target function uh from
from F to the C and and this is the
claimed result try to satisfies this
type of uh structure so you can see that
sort of the randomness uh comes in two
parts right there's a Randomness over
this constraint graph and then there's
there's the randomness over beta and the
first thing that I want to show you is
that the randomness in the constraint
graph
this is actually not necessary this can
be de-randomized easily particularly
what you actually need is that this is
an expander
and this is where we're going to see you
know expansion first enter the picture
and eventually the notion of expansion
that's useful here is going to get
generalized to some high dimensional
version
so okay exactly what notion of expansion
do I need this to Define uh to satisfy
well to do this I need to Define What's
called the boundary operator so if you
remember back from the boot camp
lectures of a Reit uh everything that
I'm doing here is going to correspond to
the boundary and co-boundary setup that
that she defined but if not I'll I'll do
it again here so the boundary operator
all right as partial this is just the
adjacency Matrix that the biparton
adjacency Matrix of this graph going
from Clauses to variables but it'll
we'll view its action over F2 we'll view
it as a
acting on F2 and in particular so maybe
I'll
find this here
the boundary operator
Delta so this Maps functions from F2 to
the C
the functions or sets on F2 to the C the
sets on on variables
and if I look uh you know if I have some
function uh
F on on this side
then Delta f
uh
of X so what's the value of this
Delta f of x is is over over here what's
the value
um
it's just going to be the mod 2 sum over
the The Neighbors on the right hand side
right this is uh the sum mod two
over the Y neighboring X of f of Y so in
this case it's the sum over Clauses that
it's contained in and this value is one
exactly when the variable appears in an
odd number of Clauses at zero when it
appears in an even number of clauses
um
this seems like a little bit of a weird
notion we'll see why it makes sense
within this context of of sum of squares
uh but I'll maybe try to give a little
bit of motivation for the moment which
is when I look at Delta f
this corresponds to the set of variables
that appears an odd number of times
over here in the clauses equivalently I
can think of this as if I sum the
variables if I sum up all the Clauses
the left side of all the clauses
Delta f is exactly the set of variables
that live through this process that
don't cancel
so the notion of boundary you know of
expansion that we're going to use is
basically going to say if I have some
you know reasonably not too huge but
reasonable set of Clauses when they when
I sum them all up there should be a lot
of variables that still exist in this uh
sum there shouldn't be a lot of
cancellations and that's going to allow
us to build uh you know over here we
sort of said that sum of squares only
gets to look at these sort of small
portions and if I can prove that you
know to find a contradiction I have to
sum up many things and see many
variables at once that's going to lead
to a lower bound against SOS that's sort
of why this is going to be useful so let
me actually formally Define a boundary
expansion
all right so we'll say this graph G uh
is an alpha alpha sum constant uh Alpha
small set
boundary
expander
if uh if for all functions on resets on
on the right side
such that they're you know linear size
that have this is just number of number
of ones that's in the in the function is
it most uh
an alpha fraction of the Clauses
um then I want uh I want this sort of
notion of boundary to be large but I
want sort of the following isothermic uh
inequality I want
uh the boundary of f to be at least
Alpha times uh
the size of f so basically the the size
of the boundary should scale with the
size uh of the function as long as I'm
not too uh large
okay so that's the that's the formal
definition
um
yeah so this direction is boundary
this direction which we will see later
is co-boundary and if we had this
property in the other direction it would
be a co-boundary expander and the
important thing is going to end up
showing some complexes that are
simultaneously satisfy both of them it
turns out but that's sort of not obvious
uh at the start
um okay so these are these are boundary
expenders
um
so I want to show you how boundary
expansion actually implies completeness
uh against against SOS since
this is what we're going to generalize
to high dimensional boundary expansion
um so the following proof
I guess formally appears in in Shawna
back it's probably not all that
different from what was originally done
by Glory of
um but China Wok proved that you know if
if the constraint graph of your instance
which I'll just write as G
is a for I'm going to ignore sort of
whatever this constant is for some
constant it's a boundary expander
this implies
uh completeness
your STP value 1 versus up up to O of n
levels
of SOS
and notice that this is a you know this
version is completely independent of the
target function it doesn't it doesn't
matter what Target function I pick we
can prove the STP value is going to be
one no matter what
okay so I want to
I want to sort of sketch this result to
give you this intuition for why this is
relevant and then eventually why the
notion of high dimensional expansion we
introduce is sort of a natural uh way to
go so the proof
foreign
luckily for us doesn't go through so
much squares it goes through proving a
refutation lower bound against the
actual resolution system so it goes
through
it's called the actual resolution
system
and this is a this is a very simple
proof system which basically says
uh you know we have some axioms that are
given by linear equations and I can
derive things by just summing the linear
equations that's the whole thing so I'll
have some axioms
okay
that corresponds to linear equations and
for us these axioms are just the Clauses
okay I said it's a j these are just the
Clauses in our uh xor instance
and then you know given two axioms we
can derive uh
the equation of their sum
so given or really just given any equals
Theta I we can derive
Li plus LJ is equal to Beta I
beta J remember these are like variables
and these are F2 values
um and okay what's the point of this
well we're going to look at how
uh you know how do I use this system to
prove that my instance is unsatisfiable
to find a contradiction right so we'll
do we'll use something called a
refutation
so very roughly a refutation is just a
way to add up the axioms together that
derive zero equals one in other words on
the left hand side I want to add them up
in a way such that all the variables
cancel I like find a cycle
um whereas on the other hand things are
going to sum to one and I get this
contradiction of zero equals one clearly
the instance can't be satisfiable so a
little bit more formally a refutation
will consist of a a dag
which has Leaf nodes that are labeled by
axioms
so I'll maybe draw a picture over here I
guess
um
so you know here we'll have uh X1 plus
X3 plus X5 is equal to zero and and here
well at X1 plus x three plus X7 is equal
to one and then
the inner nodes of the tree to the
internal nodes
have two incoming uh two incoming
children
and they're just labeled by the sum of
the equations in their children so in
this case uh you know this ends up being
like X5 plus X7 is equal to one just
summing these two equations so notice
that things sort of can can cancel when
I move throughout this tree and this is
the behavior I want to avoid
um
so internal nodes are labeled
by the sum of their children uh which
I'll just write as like L of child lefts
plus L of child rights uh equals beta
left Plus
a little informal sorry beta of child
right
um and then finally you know we'll have
sort of a bunch of these
and
eventually
these will come up to the root node
which is supposed to derive the
contradiction zero equals one so again
it's just a formal way of summing up
these equations uh that hits this
contradiction
um so root
is zero equals one
um and what's the complexity of a
refutation well it's going to be the
maximum number of variables that appear
in any of these internal nodes so the
uh width
of a refutation is the max number
of variables that appear
over the nodes
and the refutation complexity of a
instance a 3X or instance is the minimum
width over all possible different
refutations
so
the refutation width
of i n is the minimum
uh uh minimum width
over
reputations
so you know if I have reputation
complexity or reputation with 10 it
means that any way that I can derive
this solution 0 equals one I have to go
through 10 levels
um and so I have approve the following
theorem which is what's going to allow
us to ignore what's on this board over
here I shouldn't right here because of
this
um
it proved that uh
if the refutation width of ion is
greater than or equal to 2 times t
then this implies completeness
verse T levels
of SOS so if we want to prove a linear
lower bound on levels for SOS
we can do this by proving that in any
refutation I must somewhere hit a linear
number of variables in this tree
I don't think so but I'm not whenever
you know if the converse of this is true
so this can do the extra reputation
yeah
so if you uh
right so I mean if you can pull extra
Refrigeration you can fool SOS and if
you can't fool for reputation then you
certainly can't do this
right but uh
National Floor band doesn't necessarily
apply a refutation paragraph right what
are you saying
that's what I thought your question was
sorry yeah yeah okay I don't think it
does yeah
um
uh reputation is stronger than this yeah
replication should be stronger yeah
that's yeah but I don't know an explicit
example to give him this but I yeah I
think it should be
um Okay so we've reduced the problem to
showing uh large refutation with
um and now I want to show you what uh
boundary expansion
which I think I did in the race has to
has to do with this
um
and I promise eventually we'll get to
high dimensional expansion but it'll
just be some modification of this
already which is uh who I am why I'm
going through it
Okay so
uh the idea actually essentially this
was proved earlier by fantastic and
Victor said and this is like an
adjustment to 3x or I think they did it
for for stat
um and it's a beautiful argument uh
basically the idea is to track through
this refutation the number of Clauses
that you know here we're tracking sort
of the number of variables that's what
we want to prove a bound on what's much
easier is to track the number of Clauses
that appears in each internal node and I
can do this by uh defining a function
with respect to each of these nodes that
corresponds over to this picture a
function on the right hand side of
Clauses that's just a one if that Clause
is uh you know got summed into that node
and zero otherwise and okay formally I
do this by
I have this function HV for each node in
here where you know h h on the leaves is
just equal to whatever the indicator
function of whatever Clause it was so if
this was Clause two you know this would
be the indicator Vector of uh of clause
two so I put all these indicators on the
bottom of the tree and then I Define HV
just by summing these functions uh over
the children right so this is just equal
to HV of like the left child plus HV of
the of the right child and hopefully you
can see what this is tracking is exactly
like which Clauses are appearing in the
internal notes and this is again this is
some function on the right
and uh how are we going to use boundary
expansion well boundary expansion says
is that you know small set boundary
expansion it basically says if I can
find sort of any node
in here that has somewhere between say
an alpha over two fraction of the
Clauses and an alpha fraction of the
pauses so if I can find something where
the size of HV lies in here then
boundary expansion exactly tells me that
you know this can't cancel Too Much from
the left side and there have to be a
linear number of variables that appear
right in particular this forces the size
of Delta HV which is exactly the number
of variables that appear uh in this
equation this has to be greater than
Alpha times HV which is greater than
equal to Alpha squared over two uh times
M and this would give us our our width
lower bounds and bound on SOS okay so so
how do you prove this well now we've
sort of reduced to just finding
some in our node that that has many
Clauses and has as many Clauses and uh
the argument here is very simple so
we'll Define a potential function over
the nodes of the tree
which is just equal to this uh you know
size of number of Clauses that we want
to track and we'll note three things the
first thing we'll note is that the root
has potential
Kappa of root is greater than Alpha f
and roughly the reason for this is that
you know this is sums to a cycle
and moreover it's a non-zero cycle
because I can't have some zero things in
done one but boundary expansion promises
you right if my thing is of size less
than Alpha M then the boundary will be
something it'll be greater than zero so
actually this type of boundary expansion
is it's much stronger than uh this is
just something about saying there are no
small Cycles uh non-trivial Cycles so
the root has large potential second okay
clearly the leaves have potential one
right these are each indicator so the
leaves have potential one
and moreover when I you know when I add
the Clauses from here and add the
Clauses from here this this potential
function is sub-additive I can't add
five Clauses and five Clauses and end up
with 11 Clauses right it's I
you know this this satisfies that Kappa
a v is less than or equal to Kappa of
you know each the two children
okay I claim that it's not hard to see
that if I start at one and I have to end
greater than Alpha M somewhere in the
tree you know I'm adding two things I
have to pass through Alpha M over two
but if I never did I'd never be able to
reach Alpha M and and that completes the
result
this is a very nice argument
and victorson
okay so this sort of completes the proof
of completeness
um and now at least we know that if we
want to do randomized things this is not
really the hard part because we have
constructions of boundary expanders or
even like unique neighbor expanders
which imply boundary expansions unique
neighbors like I hit many things exactly
one time which is an odd number
um yeah
uh right but we don't need it for this
one because it's xor structure yeah
um
okay so clearly the issue
the hardness must be lying in this
target function
right so if I if I now wanted to
complete the proof of Gregorio or Shrine
back
um now it's really easy so you know how
how do we find
sort of unsatisfiable
beta remember these are the target
function
this is this labeling for the for the
right hand side uh okay so this original
solution was to choose it randomly
and you know why does this work well if
I have any fixed solution this generates
some number of values over on the right
hand side and if I pick them randomly on
an expectation half of them will be
correct uh and moreover by like a
churn-off bound and if I take enough
Clauses this will be true with
extraordinarily high probability and
then I can Union bound over all the
possible solutions okay so China back
proved
um so randomly works let me get this
half plus Epsilon so how do we do this
explicitly
now is there anything sort of uh
is there any reasonable way to try to
get something that's unsatisfiable well
actually
targeted how do you get the 3xr instance
Phoenix or instance is uh defined by the
constraint graph and then some labeling
on the like zero one labeling on the
constraints
right this tells you the variable
structure and then I pick some function
beta and the variable structure gets set
equal to Beta I'm not sure I'm answering
your questions
other specific the value of beta on CJ
okay good
um
so how do we find a beta explicitly
that's unsatisfied well I claim if all
you want to do is find something that's
unsatisfiable actually this is not that
hard if you don't want to get hardness
of approximation I can do this using
linear algebra
um in particular
earlier I drew this boundary operator
which is just the transpose of uh uh of
this operator the boundary operator and
what is Delta zero so
we'll Define the co-boundary operator
so again this is just the adjacency
Matrix here acting over F2 but now
moving in in this direction
um so Delta zero Maps
graph 2 to the V
to the C uh and Delta zero now I'm
applying to like a
you know a function over V where you can
think of it as an assignment uh and the
value the value of this on something on
the on the right is again just the sum
over uh
yeah let's do like Z adjacent to Y of of
f of Z okay maybe this was a needlessly
abstract way to to write it you know if
I have some assignment over here and I
want to ask what's the value of delta X
on CJ it's just the sum you know it's
exactly it's exactly this stuff right
it's the mod two sum over the variables
that include in are included in J so
it's just the Clause value of the of the
instance
so in particular I claim that this
implies the following
that the space
of
satisfiable
uh
Solutions the space of the space of beta
that lead to satisfiable instances well
what are these this is exactly the space
of things that map from some assignment
to the variables right this is exactly
where I pick some assignment here and I
see what values they give on the Clauses
and that's exactly the set of beta
that's satisfiable so in particular this
is exactly
the image of Delta zero which are
usually called the co-boundaries uh
written as uh as B1
um
I should have noted that the image of
this are usually called Boundaries that
are denoted uh
denoted by B lowercase one
um
okay so this suggests sort of a natural
strategy
using linear algebra
like gaussian elimination or something I
can just find you know pick
beta
and sorry that should be F2 to the C
without B1 I can do this explicitly
right I can find some beta that's not in
this image you know just like list the
basis vectors of this and and check and
you know this equation promises me that
this leads to an unsatisfiable instance
the problem is that you know the value
of the corresponding instance
uh you know if I pick some beta it might
be like 1 minus one over M or something
I might I might just satisf like satisfy
everything except one clause and I want
to get this like half plus Epsilon or 99
right so this is really where the where
the difficulty comes in
um
okay let me erase this
so here's sort of a very nice idea that
uh you know is from this work of dinura
film as Harsha and and told Yani
they say
you know okay why look over
what's what's really the problem here
the problem here is that F2 to the C
contain functions that were really close
to the boundary and I somehow only want
to look over things that are far away
from the boundary right intuitively
things that are far from the boundary
should be far from satisfiable but I'll
maybe write that in equation form soon
and so you know you could kind of fall
ask the following question
can we find
a Subspace that sits somewhere between
B1 and F2 to the C so we can refine some
Subspace that'll call Z1 because it'll
eventually will be co-cycles
um that sits between B1 and the entire
space
that has the following property if I
look over all of the functions in this
Subs say Z1 that are not in V1 so if I
look at the
minimum over functions in
Z1 without B1 of the distance
of f from B1
then I want this value to be linear I
want everything to be linearly far away
uh from from stuff in the satisfiable
space you know is it is it possible to
find something like this and let me
simplify this
a little bit right because this is a
Subspace that I'm that I'm picking what
is this distance this distance is the
the minimum over things in in B1
of the weight of f plus e but B1 is part
of Z1 so I'm just and and this is a
Subspace so f plus b is actually in Z so
this this minimum uh equation here is
really just the minimum Hamming weight
of anything in this set so I can replace
this
with asking if the minimum
size of f
is greater than or equal to
Alpha times M and if you're a coding
theorist there should be like alarm
Bells going off in your mind right now
because this is like asking about the
distance of the code Z1 mod B1 and this
will allow us to use coding Theory and
connections with loading Theory to solve
this problem
um
okay
um what does this have to do with high
dimensional expansion or expansion at
all we finally reached uh sort of the
point where I can discuss this
uh I'm going to redraw this diagram
over here
sorry maybe maybe I should actually
explicitly
say that uh if you can actually find
this then a claim that's easy to show is
that for any F in here if I pick this as
my target function
you know the value
of I beta will be less than or equal to
1 minus Alpha it's an easy calculation
to show this it's just a robust version
of that earlier statement it says if
something's far from the boundary then
it's then it's far from satisfiable okay
so we would be you know if we could find
this explicit Subspace on an instance
that's a boundary expander we'd be done
it turns out there's a problem with this
um and to show the problem I want to
sort of write this up uh as a higher
dimensional picture
um
okay so we still have the vertices
we have the Clauses and now here's like
a totally generic way to talk about
defining this Z1 but over in a graph
picture I can add a third layer
to the structure that essentially
corresponds to the parity checks or like
the you know generators of the
orthogonal Subspace of Z1 that defines
this space so remember we had like the
standard co-boundary you know here these
were like connected to
you know this Clause CJ was connected to
maybe X3 plus X7 plus X10 or something
and now when I Define this Subspace I'll
call this P for like parity checks the
way that I'm defining it is when I pick
beta
remember the beta that I'm picking is
some labeling some function on C I'm
going to enforce that when I sum over
the values
you know over the neighbors of each
parity check that I get zero this is a
an equivalent way of expressing this
type of uh Subspace
um
and okay so in this diagram
somehow uh sorry I guess I should say
that when I do this
this is again just the adjacency
operator running in this direction and
what is Z1 in this picture Z1 is the
kernel
of this operator Delta one right so this
this is basically the parity check
Matrix corresponding to this Subspace
everything that's in the kernel of this
operator
um
so we just want something that uh you
know Z1
has this uh has this minimum distance
property and I'll mention that when
you're in a complex these are called
co-cycles
and this property of having everything
being of weight greater than or equal to
Alpha m is called cosistolic distance
so this is uh that property over there
was I'll just say having good post
systolic distance
uh okay so what's the point I want to
sort of build some complex like this
that simultaneously has good coaster
like distance so sort of good properties
in this direction and I want it to be a
boundary expander right I want to to get
completeness I want this result of
shrine and back so I want to show that
that in this direction at least from C
to v
um you know small sets in here expand to
many things here but this is a problem
because
in in how I Define this by picking uh
you know B1 within Z1 what I've
implicitly done
you know okay so this is the kernel of
Delta one right and this was the image
of the first operator so the fact that
B1 is in Z1 means when I map something
from here to here
it's in the kernel which means when I
map it again I get zero which means this
whole complex necessarily satisfies the
relation uh Delta zero Delta one equals
zero which is what's called being a
chain complex and it's used in you know
studied heavily in algebraic topology in
lots of areas and it's you know has very
useful things we can draw on but here
it's a little bit problematic because
you know if Delta one Delta zero is zero
then when I look at the boundary
operators which are as transposes
this means that Delta Delta is is also
zero why is that a problem because you
know look at this parity check that I've
drawn I claim that when I have this
structure this means that there is going
to be a small non-expanding set in this
graph no matter what I do because when I
look at you know just applying Delta to
you know the indicator of this parity
check I get like a set of size four here
and because it has to be you know it's
forced to be in the kernel that maps to
nothing over here gives a short cycle so
this this graph you know shown MX
results is going to break down because
this graph is not you know can because
of this High dimensional component it
cannot be a small set expander Okay so
we've seen this occur in maybe 50 of the
talks at the boot camp and the workshop
so far we had some notion of small set
expansion or expansion we moved to some
different object like HDX or the
Grossman or something like this and and
these objects had sort of these
canonical local bad sets that didn't
expand and what did we prove well every
time we found some way to show that as
long as you're not correlated with one
of these functions as long as I'm far
from this set of canonical bad elements
then I will maintain this type of iso
perimetry I'll maintain this expansion
and this is what I call a small set High
dimensional expansion or at least in the
boundary Direction so we'll Define
uh
a small you know Alpha small set
boundary
HDX corresponds to one of these sort of
three-term chains where uh let's just
mimic the definition that was going on
over here
for all functions in this middle layer
and F2 to the C that have size are less
than an alpha fraction
of the graph
then we want that the boundary the size
of the boundary
okay I wanted to write F here but I just
showed you that that can't possibly be
true
yeah
counter example codes only if the degree
of from yeah that's good if these are
all high degree so it's possible you
might be able to get this result to work
if you pick something High degree okay I
was thinking about this last night I
don't know how to instruct such a thing
but if you could I think it would get
your own SOS power math in fact there
are other things that maybe like you
could also try to find Z1 that's not in
V1 and there are some reasons why or
that doesn't have this containment and
then you also wouldn't have this but
this has some other reasons you might
not want to do it I didn't want to get
too much too much yeah very good point
um so the constructions that we have
these will be they'll come from like
ldpc codes meaning that these will
actually be some constant and so they
will truly give you non-expanding sets
okay let me finally get to the the
payoff because I'm pretty close to out
of time
um which is that instead of the weight
of f which is what we would have had
here an expansion now that we have this
extra Dimension Center we have these
canonical non-expanding functions which
uh let's write
the these are the canonical
non-expanding things are the image of
this map these are usually called the
boundaries I think I did the wrong
definition over here should have been b0
sorry about that
um we want that this is Alpha times the
distance of Apple
to the matters and so this is sort of
the best possible thing you could hope
for because the boundaries are these
canonical families of non-expecting
sense and I'll mention if you want to
write this as sort of a more classical
you know look something like this as a
classical ISO parametric inequality
um we can do the thing that of like
defining Global functions we're usually
here they're called minimal so if f
is you know small and
it's called minimal which means that I
can't add a boundary to it and reduce
the weight then I would
uh
I would recover actually this in this
ISO parametric
um and I I don't have time and I wasn't
going to go through it anyway did I
erase the I did erase the proof of a
oh no it's okay no it's not over here so
we saw this proof of the refutation
proof where we used the potential
function
um
you know we used we use this as the
potential function right we we looked at
the we had this tree
and we looked at sort of the number of
Clauses that was maintained in each
thing I'm just going to repeat this
proof or I'm not but but you can and in
fact it's done in this earlier work
dinner film is harsham and tulsiani they
did it in a special case of the
ramonesian complex and used a much
weaker ISO parametric inequality of grow
moth but the same ideas are are there
you just replace the potential function
now with this distance
and you have to be a little bit careful
but the whole proof goes through so you
know just replacing sort of standard
isoprimacy with this ISO perimetry for
minimal functions or high dimensional
version of the isoprimetry gives you the
completeness result back
um so I okay I have one or two minutes
you know this is all all well and good
but this is useless unless I can
actually build complexes that satisfy
these two Notions so this is the final
theorem which I was hoping to actually
say something
about the proof but I probably won't
have uh time uh
which is indeed these objects exist and
in fact something even stronger exists
so there exists uh explicit
infinite family
of you know I'll call these complexes
like capital X or something so some
some infinite family of these explicit
complexes uh
such that
for all functions
in the middle
people probably can't see this can they
yeah okay
um
sorry nf2 to the C uh the first thing is
that we have this guarantee right we
have boundary expansion
uh
distance of f from B1 and moreover the
constructions are symmetric so we
actually have it fully in the other
direction as well
two
um
it also has what I'd call co-boundary
expansion in the other direction
that's writing this this sense of f
yeah
oh I forgot to write that yes yeah so
actually by the way this is just like a
small set version of the classical
Notions of boundary and co-boundary
expansion I mean it's a very natural
definition which I read covered in her
talks and actually something that's
that's interesting that I'll note
um is when we did this proof we had to
pick something that was in this set
which in topology terms mean that you
have non-trivial poemology and actually
if you're a full co-boundary expander or
boundary expander you'll always have
trivial homology so you actually you
know the stronger version of the serum
actually will not work to prove SOS star
amounts you need to have this small set
version of the result
um which is sort of interesting uh yeah
this should be less than or equal to
Alpha times
okay
um yeah unfortunately I'm out of time so
I'll I'll just say like one minute how
in the world do you construct these
objects
um it turned out that most of the hard
work was already done for us
um by coding theorists and by previous
people in the HDX uh Community it turns
out that these breakthrough works on
Quantum ldpc codes constructed chain
complexes that looked like this
um which had a slightly weaker guarantee
they had sort of this distance I
probably erased it at this point but
they had this thing that I called
cosistolic distance which was when uh
you know this this minimum was greater
than equal to Alpha M and they had it in
in both directions and basically what
you need to prove for this result is to
sort of upgrade you know Coast to solid
distance is sort of like having no short
Cycles versus having boundary expansion
and you just sort of need to upgrade
their their proof
um from no short Cycles to having this
relevant notion of high dimensional
expansion and you know the way that it's
done is you construct this High
dimensional object via what are called
the Left Right Kaylee complexes I won't
go too much into it but somehow you like
put some squares in the in the middle
and you put some codes on the squares
and these defined maps in both
directions and you you place some
objects on the squares that are robustly
testable or like have co-boundary
expression in some sense and then you
use spectral expansion of sort of the
global object to lift this robust
testability to small cycle boundary
expansion of everything
um okay I think I'm out of time at this
point so I'll I'll finish yeah thanks
any questions for Max
I have the following a question so let's
say you take the neighborhood of uh one
of the weirdest things on the right most
partition so so that that gives you like
an even cover inside the exercise
if you're in a chain complex if you're
if you're into being complex yeah I I
guess you're you're saying that these if
you added the Clauses and leaves even
cupboards on the variable side you're
gonna get zero yeah uh how do you know
that on the
Target function side
like like what do we set as a right hand
side free class that also gives you zero
when we do this like Subspace thing
we're always gonna when we actually do
the SOS event we're always going to pick
beta that's in uh Z1 without
foreign
and because it's in the neighborhood of
one week vertices it actually
like with battery checks make make it
yeah
fall inside like Z100
yeah okay that's the definition of this
yeah yeah sounds good I think
is
2xr should be easy right so is
there a
uh
[Music]
um
I don't know you knew this was like
reductions in the hierarchy I'm not sure
how you would do this directly I mean
okay I'm I'm lying in that like already
this actually doesn't mean you're a 3X
order instance it gives you like maybe
like 100x or instance because we don't
have like degree three versions of the
title Metro offenders so already I have
to sort of do some reduction within the
hierarchy to get the 3x or I don't know
if you can do uh no not really an expert
at that if you can do some sort of PCP
reduction
like direct like unique games that's
what you're saying yeah so of course
it's hard yeah yeah
right okay sure yeah
more questions
I mean though here you have like this
equipment
aggressive let's think once again
[Applause]
so Weber reception now I believe and
otherwise we'll see you next